we have an economy that's moving in the
right direction it's booming history and
in terms we have never seen the
president and chief of staff have had
full confidence and trust in his
abilities and his performance I told
them all of the details of my marriage
including verbal and emotional abuse I
think a lot of us could have done better
homie he's gone McCabe has left the FBI
Lisa page has been demoted Peters truck
has been demoted it's so much fun we're
like the great sleuth was fired three
times on the apprentice and this is the
fourth time we let her go we're
traveling to the Olympics - I would
describe it Deena as a collective I role
from military leaders who I've spoken to
most thought it was a joke at first of
all the things I thought I thought might
be hungry I thought I might be thirsty I
thought I might I never thought I'd get
the sniffles from the rug I don't know
that for eight hours if he lets the
freedom caucus be the tail that wags the
dog there's no way we'll reach an
agreement that can pass the Senate I'm
not only know I'm a helmet
the last nickname he gave me was sleazy
Adam Schiff now just little Adam Schiff
which seems like an improvement we've
made a lot of improvements haven't we
Amnon braggadocious that's an especially
notable week